طيب براءه يعني دائما ما يقال انه الكل
سواء رجل او امراه يستحق فرصه ثانيه كما
يقال ايضا الرجال من المريخ والنساء من
الزهره اختلاف العقل الرجل يتعامل مع
الماديات والمراه تتعامل مع المشاعر او
الاحاسيس كيفيه اتخاذ هذا القرار على اي
اسس تضعينها كيف اتخذ بخطوات اذا تكرمتي
ممكن تروح هاي العلاقه بتتطور
ولكن لا يستطيع اي انسان اخذ قرار الطلاق
عن العميل لانه هو وحده سيتحمل المسؤوليه
فانا اساعد اوجهه ولكن انا لا اتخذ القرار
عنه
هذا رقم واحد وكل انسان بوعدكن لما بيكون
بشوف انه هاي العلاقه فيها امل بيعطي فرصه
ما في حدا بحب انه يحمي علاقته او يرجع
للطلاق اكيد الله لا يجيب طلاق يعني
ويضلوا الناس محبين لبعضهم البعض يعني في
علاقاتهم الزوجيه شكرا جزيلا لك لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات